AstraZeneca may be able to help.
>> Laura: TIME NOW FOR OUR
SEEN AND UNSEEN SEGMENT WHERE WE
EXPOSE WHAT IS REALLY GOING ON
BEHIND THE BIG CULTURE STORIES
OF THE DAY, WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
THE SWIMSUIT EDITION HITS THE
"ME TOO" ERA.
WE’LL SHARE ANOTHER SWEET STORY
COMING UP, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
RAYMOND ARROYO, SWIMSUIT
EDITION, NO SWIMSUITS BUT A
HASHTAG ON THE MODELS, WHAT’S
GOING ON?
>> THESE ARE EMPOWERING WORDS ON
THESE SUPERMODELS.
HERE’S THE PROBLEM, THEY ARE
SAYING THIS IS EMPOWERING,
YOU’RE USING THEM AS LITERAL
BILLBOARDS.
I’M SORRY, THIS IS NO WAY.
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO RAISE
AWARENESS OF RESPECT FOR WOMEN,
SEXUAL ABUSE AWARENESS, THIS IS
AN ODD WAY TO DO IT BY PUTTING
THE FIRST TIME IN HISTORY
"SPORTS ILLUSTRATED" DOES A
SPREAD.
>> Laura: ALL WOMEN EDITED
THIS ADDITION, THEY DIDN’T EDIT
MUCH.
HERE’S WHAT THE EDITOR SAID OF
THIS EXPERIENCE.
SHE SAID IT’S ABOUT ALLOWING
WOMEN TO EXIST IN THE WORLD
WITHOUT BEING HARASSED OR
JUDGED, REGARDLESS OF HOW THEY
LIKE TO PRESENT THEMSELVES.
>> WOMEN MAY READ THE WORDS, MEN
ARE READING THE CURVES.
THIS IS A PHOTO SPREAD THAT
HARVEY WEINSTEIN COULD HAVE
PRODUCED, IT’S AN OUTRAGE.
>> Laura: LADIES, YOU’RE
EMBARRASSING YOURSELVES.
A FATHER DAUGHTER DANCE CANCELED
IN NEW YORK, MY DAUGHTER HAS
GONE TO A FATHER DAUGHTER DANCE,
SHE GOES WITH A FRIEND OR A
SURROGATE GRANDFATHER AND SHE
HAS A GREAT TIME.
>> THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS HAVE A
CODE THAT YOU DON’T WANT TO
VIOLATE ANYONE’S GENDER
IDENTIFICATION AND BY CALLING IT
A FATHER DAUGHTER DANCE THEY SAY
YOU’RE EXCLUDING PEOPLE.
I DON’T UNDERSTAND THIS, IF
YOU’RE A MOTHER WHO IDENTIFIES
AS A FATHER, GO TO THE FATHER
DAUGHTER DANCE.
>> Laura: I’M STAYING HOME, I
FIND THIS WHOLE THING -- THIS IS
A DIFFERENT TYPE OF DANCE, IT’S
NOT THE DANCES I’M USED TO.
>> THESE ARE BEAUTIFUL EVENTS
FOR A FATHER AND DAUGHTER, THEY
LEAVE LASTING MEMORIES.
WHY SHOULD IT BE RUINED FOR
EVERYBODY?
>> Laura: THEY WANT TO RUIN
THE BOY SCOUTS, GIRL SCOUTS,
ALL-MALE CLUBS, ALL-FEMALE
CLUBS, YOU CAN’T HAVE ANY FUN
WITH A PARTICULAR GROUP BECAUSE
EVERYBODY HAS TO BE IN.
>> DOWN AT PS 30 THEY HAVE
SOMETHING CALLED A FUDGE DANCE
COME UP WITH UNCLES, DANCE,
GRANDFATHERS, ET CETERA, LOOK
FOR THE ET CETERA DANCE.
EVERYONE WILL BE HAPPY THEN.
>> Laura: WHAT’S A FEEL GOOD
STORY.
>> GERBER BABY HAS CHOSEN X
BOATS         IT’S
SPOKES MAY BE OF THE YEAR.
DOWN SYNDROME, SUCH A LESSON AND
A WITNESS, 67, 90% OF CHILDREN
WITH DOWN SYNDROME ARE ABORTED.
THIS IS A LESSON FOR THE BEAUTY
AND A NEED FOR EVERY LIFE, THESE
PEOPLE ARE VALUED AND LOVED AND
SHOULD BE.
>> Laura: EVERY LIFE HAS WORTH